trumpeting another landmark moments in
the flow of British history
the Queen arrived at Cadogan Pier with a
Duke of Edinburgh the monarch
accompanied to the royal launch by her
son the Prince of Wales and the Duchess
of Cornwall as hundreds of boats began
mustering up River the Queen made her
way to the elaborately decked spirit of
Chartwell the royal barge
the prince Elizabeth steam train blew
her horn from the Chelsea river bridge
she went already on board the barge her
grandsons and the Duchess of Cambridge
waiting in the light drizzle the vibrant
gold and red of the velvet drapes and
gilt covered statues cutting through the
June gloom once aboard the man powered
vessels prepare to take up their
position at the head of the flotilla at
2:40 the wheels on the floating belfry
began to spin the bells marking the
start of the pageant on cue the boats
rowed past the Queen at their head many
other members of the royal family on
board the Gloriana they received a wave
of royal assent in all there are two
hundred and sixty-five man powered
vessels taking part in the pageant now
many of those on board are used to
competing going as fast as possible
where they've been told to slow it down
today to a maximum of four knots as they
make their way through the center of the
city
as they kept that pace the spirit of
Chartwell slipped its moorings and
joined the procession cheers from the
thousands watching on the riverbank as
the flotilla took shape moving down the
seven mile route under 14 road foot and
rail bridges its historical inspiration
became clear
organizers studied this painting by
Canaletto marketing Lord Mayor's day in
1746 the visual echo is staggering Henry
the eighth and Charles the second all
used the Thames for their own
celebrations
there was a musical reminder to as one
of 10 floating music barges played
Handel's water music commissioned in
1717 by George the first everywhere
though reflections of the Queen six
decades on the throne countries and the
Commonwealth also represented while
others went for less traditional boat
decorations the chilly day drew comment
on board the charred well as it passed
the South Bank cultural center the home
of the National Theatre where there was
a carefully coordinated salute
the puppet star of the war horse rearing
over the Thames obviously enjoyed by the
royal viewing party
then the Queen passed an enormous
reminder of another milestone a
black-and-white photograph from the
Silver Jubilee in 1977 as the barge
approached the finishing line a trumpet
salute
then the bass goals of Tower Bridge were
raised as the rain fell
the spirit of chard well Maude as the
Royal party move to watch the rest of
the flotilla pass
if the drizzle and pageantry wasn't
British enough the musicians added to
the pomp and circumstance
Robert Nesbitt Sky News